[Música]
hoy en directo a vamos a hasta Argentina
porque la justicia de ese país emitió
una orden de detención contra cuatro
ciudadanos libaneses que estarían
involucrados en el atentado de 1994
contra la mutual israelita Argentina
amia en Buenos Aires ese ataque cobró la
vida de 85 personas y siguen la
impunidad para ampliar esta información
conectamos en la capital Argentina con
nuestro corresponsal natalio cosoy
natalio Buenas noches Quiénes son estas
personas que busca la justicia y cuáles
son los señalamientos en su contra
son cuatro ciudadanos libaneses
lo señalan como partícipes secundarios
del atentado el juez Federal Daniel
rafeca solicitó su captura internacional
o nacional
tres de ellos se estima que podrían
estar en la zona de la triple frontera
entre Argentina Paraguay y Brasil 1 se
cree que puede estar en el Líbano todas
estas información que ha salido en la
prensa local que ha accedido a fuentes
de la investigación el fiscal es el que
le pide al juez estos pedidos de captura
es el fiscal Sebastián basso que quiere
tomarles declaración indagatoria
se sospecha sospechan los investigadores
que estas personas Podrían haber
cooperado que le Podrían haber
facilitado el accionar aquellos que
organizaron
efectivamente el atentado sus nombres
son hussein murir musanar Alí hussein
abdala faruk Abdul hay omariri y abdala
salman que también es conocido con el
alias de José elreda bueno Y aunque hay
algunas condenas dentro de esta causa
los principales acusados aún no han sido
llevados a la justicia cómo ha avanzado
esta investigación con el pasar de los
años
es una causa que ha tenido muchísimas
dificultades muchísimas ideas y vueltas
investigaciones paralelas por
encubrimiento también hay es un área
clave bueno en la investigación la
sospecha recae sobre personas que tenían
algún tipo de vínculo de poder dentro de
lo que era la República islámica de Irán
y también creen los investigadores que
fue ejecutado el atentado por gesbolá en
la organización extremista libanesa de
hecho hay un pedido de captura de hace
muchísimos años a 10 ciudadanos iraníes
que no logra concretarse ese pedido
captura internacional no logra
concretarse y de hecho nunca han podido
ser indagados por la justicia Argentina
es una causa que como digo muchas veces
parece que avanza como en la noticia de
hoy pero finalmente no aparecen los
resultados Porque desde el inicio ha
tenido muchísimas dificultades para su
investigación y esclarecimiento